si vous avez des restrictions qui
limitent vos capacités la vice-première
ministre landreau à quelques détails
mais je vais vous en donner quelques uns
tous nous devons faire ce qu'il faut
pour protéger les canadiens et pour que
vous ayez besoin de poser ce dont vous
avez besoin pour passer au travers de
cette vague et surtout nous allons
travailler avec les régions de l'est
plus touché où les secteurs les plus
touchés comme le tourisme la culture
d'hospitalité et nous voulons que vous
restiez en sécurité nous allons
continuer de travailler de concert avec
les provinces et territoires et nous
serons là pour vous soutenir dans les
louis photo ne déborde pas avec plus de
80% des gens pleinement vacciner 1 vous
avez fait la bonne chose il vous est
fort ed
ceux qui sont pas encore accédé à l'isi
et par rapport aux booster sachez en ont
assez de dose de rappel pour tous les
canadiens qui sont admissibles alors à
l'isie des xive autour on sait que adil
aux deux rappels vont aider gatx boost
chante we have est allé chercher votre
rappel nous avons suffisamment de doses
pour tous tous ceux qui en ont besoin
alors s'il vous plaît allez vous faire
vacciner vous allez recevoir votre
rappel
pour que tout le monde soit sécuritaire
les 25e pédiatriques sont toujours donné
et
ça va être très important qu'on fasse
absolument tout ce qui est possible pour
qu'on passe plus passer au travers de
cette vague nous savons aussi que les
tests rapides sont font partie de la
solution donc nous avons déjà distribué
85 millions de
pour les provinces et territoires
jusqu'au 22 décembre et nous allons
livrer 35 millions de plus et nous avons
des dizaines et des dizaines de millions
de tests rapides qui arrive d'ici
quelques semaines pour l'année prochaine
donc les provinces les territoires
pourront suffisamment pour les
distribuer aux gens nous avons besoin
aussi de suivre les directives des
directives de santé pour protéger nos
proches et pour côté j'ai aussi les gens
les professionnels de la santé je sais
que tout le monde en a assez c'est vrai
je le comprends et personne n'aimerait
être là nous sommes fatigués l'aco vide
nous voulons voyager nous voulons faire
tant de choses mais nous savons que ça
ne sonnera pas tout de suite donc
surtout quand vous pensez à quel point
vous êtes
épuisé d'avoir géré cette crise de
l'accueil vip qui continue et qui
continue et qui continue sachez qu'il ya
des gens qui sont encore plus fatigué
vous un exemple les travers la santé ils
n'ont pas eu beaucoup de vacances depuis
les dernières de ces deux dernières
années et certains continuent à
travailler et à travailler pour que les
gens soient sécuritaires et en sécurité
ils sont dans les hôpitaux pour aider
les gens il dit il donne des vaccins et
la distribuer des tests se sont
pratiquement des héros ils ont été là
pour nous à toutes les étapes de cette
processus ce processus et maintenant
c'est à nous être là pour eux nous avons
besoin
de faire en sorte que le mikron ne
met pas notre système de santé
en difficulté et il faut vraiment nous
garder en toute sécurité parce que au
micro est vraiment très contagieux et il
faut que nous montrions notre soutien
envers ces gens qui nous ont
qui nous ont aidés tout le long tout au
long de la
covin et nous savons que micron est
extrêmement contagieux et se propage je
me sens très rapide dans le monde entier
est ici et il y en a partout moi je ne
suis pas immunisés dans mon bureau il y
a trois membres de mon personnel et
trois personnes membres de mon personnel
de sécurité qui sont maintenant positifs
et ils ont quand même suivi toutes les
directives se sentent et c'est ce que je
fais aussi est ce que tout le monde
devrait faire mais c'est simplement pour
vous dire à quel point le virus est
partout et que c'est vraiment une menace
et qu'il faut vraiment se protéger a
semblé comme il l'aurait voulu ma part
j'ai alors de passer du temps de qualité
avec ma famille proche un nez il y aura
pas de partis ou de rassemblement si la
réalité à laquelle nous faisons tous
face
de fait news la wii nommé
nous savons ce qu'il faut faire ce qui
marche parce que les canadiens ont
montré depuis deux ans qu'on est capable
de faire les choses pour les uns et pour
les autres nous savons quoi faire nous
savons qu'il faut porter des masques
comment faire nous savons qu'il faut
garder nos distances nous savons qu'il
faut éviter les contacts et si nous
faisons de façon
appropriée au cours des prochaines
semaines eh bien nous allons passer tous
un meilleur hiver est probablement un
bien meilleur printemps parce que
personne franchement envie d'être dans
cette situation mais les canadiens ont
montré qu'ils étaient capables de faire
des efforts pour leurs voisins pour les
autres et il était là aussi pour les
travailleurs de la santé nous avons des
vaccins nous avons d'équipement
personnel nous avons un test rapide nous
savons quoi faire
et nous allons le faire parce que c'est
ce que nous sommes en tant que canadien
où on serre les uns les autres on prend
les choix qu'il faut pour que tout le
monde soit en sécurité et nous savons
que l'hiver vais dire mais le printemps
va arriver et le printemps va être
dernière
surtout si nous nous faisons cette ce
confinement pendant quelques semaines
quelques semaines
tout le monde dans les derniers jours
nous avons constaté une montée des cas
de kobe 19 certaines régions du pays
génial dénombre du cap trégor le varien
omikron de virus est beaucoup plus
facilement transmissible que les autres
et nous ne pouvons pas nous montrer
qu'on plaisante depuis le début de la
pandémie nous nous efforçons d'être
souple et de nous adapter à la nature
changeante de la pandémie à l'intérieur
de nos programmes nous nous assurons de
prévoir la marche du monde oeuvre
nécessaires afin de réagir rapidement et
efficacement
la semaine dernière nous avons fait
adopter le projet de loi c 2
cette loi a permis la mise en place de
mesures ciblées pour soutenir les
travailleurs les entreprises si des
condiments étaient nécessaires pour
contenir la propagation du virus au
moins d'octobre lorsque nous avons
présenté ces mesures plus ciblées nous
ne connaissons pas encore le variant au
micro ondes mais nous nous sommes
assurés d'être prêt
tué aujourd'hui par le biais de pouvoir
réglementaire a prouvé lors de
l'adoption de 2 du projet de loi c 2
nous annonçons notre nom son intention
d'élargir temporairement la définition
du confinement afin que ces programmes
puissent soutenir les travailleurs et
les entreprises dont la capacité est
réduite
de 50% ou plus
alors qu'est ce que cela signifie
exactement
cela signifie que si vous êtes un
employeur qui doit réduire la capacité
de son entreprise principale de 50% ou
plus vous serez admissibles à cette aide
sous forme de subvention salariale et de
loyer dans le cadre du programme local
de confinement et nous abaissons le
seuil de diminution des revenus de 40 %
à 25 %
les employeurs admissibles recevront des
subventions salariales et locatives
allant de 25 à 75%
selon l'ampleur de la perte des revenus
à laquelle ils sont confrontés et votre
organisation doit seulement montré une
perte de revenus pendant le mois en
cours par rapport à celui de 2010 9 les
employeurs pourront demander ses
soutiens élargi après la fin de chaque
période de programmes de la même manière
qu'ils ont reçu un soutien au titre de
subventions salariales ou locative
depuis le lancement des programmes
l'année d'avenir pour les travailleurs
cela signifie que si vous travaillez
dans une région où le gouvernement
provincial ou territorial a introduit de
l'instruction de capacité de 50% ou plus
et si vous avez perdu
50% ou plus de votre revenu en
conséquence directe de cette instruction
vous pouvez être admissibles à la
prestation
de confinement fin pour le confinement
des travailleurs au canada cette
prestation m à 300 $ par semaine dans
l'autre poule pour compenser la perte de
salaire
c'était largement proposée de
l'admissibilité entre en vigueur
dernier a en effet en train de trimer
dimanche dernier le 19 décembre 2021 et
se poursuivra jusqu'au 12 février 2022
de nombreuses régions du pays ont déjà
annoncé des restrictions de santé
publique petits courts circuits afin de
freiner l'augmentation des cas
ces mesures de soutien élargi
permettront provinces et aux autorités
de santé publique de continuer à prendre
les bonnes décisions pour sauver des
vies
tout ans chants que le gouvernement
fédéral sera là pour soutenir
financièrement les travailleurs et les
entreprises dans cette lutte
notre gouvernement sait que d'autres
entreprises pour touché par la pandémie
et puis hier les employeurs admissibles
peuvent demander une aide financière
par le biais ce disque au kram de près
lens pour que le tourisme et l'accueil
et du programme de relance pour que les
entreprises et plus durement touchés des
programmes offrent des subventions
salariales et dead ou loyers pouvant
atteindre 75 % et 50 % respectivement
lorsque nous avons annoncé ces
programmes en octobre nous aimant qu'il
allait coûter 7,4
milliards de dollars la semaine dernière
dont la mise à jour économique et
budgétaire nous avons mis de côté une
montant de
4,5 milliards de dollars en prévision du
l'impact du variant au micro le coup de
l'archi semant des programmes de soutien
est estimé à 4 milliards de dollars et
sera entièrement couverte par le montant
prévu dans la mise à jour
l ennui ou ethnique et finalement je
trais que les entreprises publiques qui
reçoivent une subvention salariale dans
le cadre de ses programmes de soutien et
qui augmente la rémunération de leurs
cadres supérieurs en 2022 par rapport à
2010 neuf pourrait voir cette aide
récupérer
16 prise de viendront également
inadmissible si elles versent des
dividendes tout en recevant la
subvention salariale
donc comme la docteure taille ne l'a
rappelé la semaine dernière toutes les
pandémies ont une fin
l'émergence
propagation virulente du variant un
micron
nous a tous
en fête ne paye pas la bienvenue
cela arrive à un moment difficile à un
moment où nous sommes
tous fatigués et c'est surtout le cas
pour nos travers de la santé cependant
je sais que
nous pouvons et nous devons faire
tout ce qui est en notre pouvoir pour
vaincre cette pandémie
pour gagner la lutte contre la corrida
et canal sont intelligents ils savent
quand il faut se serrer les coudes
nous avons les outils
dont nous avons besoin d outils
de santé et
si de soutien financier qui nous
permettront de vaincre l'aco vide
avec les programmes de soutien fédéraux
énergie les canadiens pourront respecter
les restrictions de santé publique tout
en sachant que le gouvernement fédéral
est là pour les soutenir merci
j'aimerais maintenant donner la parole à
mon collègue
ma collègue la ministre car la coach aux
hormones j'aimerais vous parler
brièvement de la façon dont nous
soutenons les travailleurs canadiens
face à cette crise de santé publique qui
évolue rapidement nous avons constaté
récemment une augmentation nombre de
personnes qui ont reçu une résultat
positif aux castes dépistage de la
colline 19 partis au canada une
constation une fois de plus que des
régions et des provinces imposent des
restrictions de capacité et
malheureusement des fermetures complètes
ou partielles ma propre provinces la
colombie-britannique a annoncé des
mesures rapides qu'à cueillir
si nous avons appris quelque chose de
cette pandémie c'est que la kfw 19 et
imprévisible et que nous ne savons pas
ce qui nous attend
malheureusement nous savions que nous
pourrions nous retrouver dans une
situation où il y aurait l'imposition de
nouvelles mesures de santé publique à
l'échelle régionale pour endiguer la
propagation de lakovic 19 ainsi lorsque
nous avons introduit le projet de loi c
2 qui comprennent la prestation de
confinement pour les travailleurs
canadiens nous nous sommes assurés de
prévoir une certaine souplesse rennes
pour être agile faire des ajustements
pour sauter et travers canadiens payent
des besoins en étudiant la sens
l'association de santé publique nous
avons constaté la nécessité d'élargir
l'admissibilité à l'apprécient
prestations pour les canadiens dont
l'emploi est touché par un confinement
partiel une réduction de capacité c'est
pourquoi nous apportons aujourd'hui les
ajustements nécessaires et temporaire à
la prestation afin d'élargir la
définition d'un ordre de confinement
pour inclure les travailleurs qui ont
face à des réductions des heures de
travail en raison des restrictions de
capacité de 50% ou plus
les travers et demi c'est pour y
recevoir 300 $ par semaine s'ils ont
perdu du travail en raison directe d'un
ordre de confinement pour des raisons de
santé publique la prestation canadienne
pour les travers un code confinement
s'ajoute à la prestation de maladie et
la prestation pour aidants naturels du
canada les deux sont toujours
disponibles au travers canadien nous
comprenons que les canadiens puissent se
sentir découragés par la récente
augmentation des cas de vide et les
positions de nouvelles mesures de santé
publique surtout à cette période de
l'année amy que la situation évolue
rapidement partout au pays nous
continuerons à soutenir les travailleurs
canadiens comme nous l'avons fait tout
au long de la pandémie
j'aimerais maintenant céder la parole à
mon collègue le ministre duclos
carla et bonjour à tous et à toutes
c'est avec grand plaisir que je me joins
à vous de façon virtuelle aujourd'hui
thank you obéir merci de votre présence
je tiens gentil à vous présenter une
courte mise à jour sur la situation
actuelle concernant la coved 19 même si
nous espérions tous et toutes un autre
genre de période des fêtes
il y a bien des raisons
d'être optimiste les vaccins pour les
adultes et les enfants sont offerts à
grande échelle et l'administration des
doses de rappel c'est ainsi partout au
pays
grâce aux plus vastes programmes de
vaccination de l'histoire du canada en
cette fin d'année plus de 80% des
personnes admissibles au canada sont
pleinement vacciner et elles sont des
gars là a homologué le vaccin de bayeux
pour les enfants de 5 à 11 ans jusqu'au
11 décembre 32 % des enfants de 5 à 11
ans au canada ont reçu une dose de
vaccin le tout en seulement trois
semaines voilà des réalisations
remarquables
nous serions dans une situation beaucoup
plus difficile au pays si nous n'allions
pas des taux de vaccinations aussi élevé
je veux donc et tout d'abord remercier
tous ceux et toutes celles qui se sont
déjà fait vacciner cette année
maintenant que les lots de rappel sont
disponibles pour le plus grand nombre je
vous encourage tout et tout ça prend
notre troisième rendez vous si ce n'est
pas encore fait mais il faut les
vaccinés 2nde être pleinement vacciner
et ensuite recevoir une dose de rappel
du vaccin basé ou de modern à contribuer
à vous offrir une protection contre
l'infection et la maladie
j'aimerais m'exprimer en termes clairs
dès que vous être admissible que ce soit
pour recevoir une dose de phase ii ou
moderna vous devriez prendre la première
dose de rappel
qui est disponible si vous n'êtes pas
encore vaccinés ce n'est pas trop tard
chaque nouvelle personne vaccinée
contribue à nous protéger contre à covè
19 de même qu'à protéger sa santé et sa
sécurité
le gouvernement du canada continue de
travailler en étroite collaboration avec
les provinces les territoires et les
partenaires en santé publique pour
accélérer le déploiement des campagnes d
administration d dose de rappel près de
5 millions de canadiens ont déjà reçu
une dose de rappel
suffisamment de vaccins
messager pour administrer plus de 22
millions de dons ou de labels partout au
pays des millions et des millions
d'autres doses seront livrées au cours
des prochaines semaines et des prochains
mois les stocks de dons de la baie sont
suffisants pour faire une dose de rappel
à toutes les personnes admissibles au
pays ce soit des lacs simple phase où
moderna ils sont tous les deux sur et
efficace permettez moi d'insister dès
que vous êtes admissible il s'agisse de
father who de modern art vous devriez
prendre la première dose à la paix s
disponible
le gamin du canada le gouvernement du
canada continue également à travailler
en étroite collaboration avec les
provinces et les territoires pour
accroître l'accès aux tests de dépistage
rapide partout au pays
comme vous en êtes peut-être conscient
sept territoires décès de la meilleure
façon de tester et d'administrer le
vaccin puisque c'est de leur
responsabilité d'administrer les
services de santé
on fait ce que la stratégie de
distribution garantissent un accès
équitable au vaccin pour tous les
canadiens
au pays les tests de dépistage rapide
sont une couche de protection de plus
pour nous protéger contre la coved 19
tout comme le sont les masques une bonne
hygiène la distanciation physique la
bonne ventilation et bien évidemment la
vaccination les tests de dépistage
rapide permettent de déceler les
personnes qui excrète le virus en plus
grande quantité et ce malgré le fait que
c'était soit moins sensible que les
tests pcr moléculaire ici une
intervention rapide mais il est crucial
de se rappeler que ces tests ne sont pas
parfaits si vous obtenez un résultat
négatif continuent d'être prudents en
présence d'une personne que vous
pourriez à être aux premiers stades de
l'infection et pourriez donc infecté
aussi les autres si vous obtenez un
résultat positif il est crucial de vous
isoler et de suivre les conseils de
santé publique de votre localité sur la
livraison des tests rapides
la majorité des 35 millions de tests
rapides commandés dans les provinces et
les territoires pour le mois de décembre
ont déjà été livrés les tests restants
seront reçus avant la fin du mois et les
dizaines de millions de tests
additionnels arriveront en janvier et en
février
sans qu'une dynamique
continue aussi à augmenter la
description test rapide au canada
pour cette période des fêtes nous
travaillons avec la croix rouge
canadienne et d'autres organisations
comme des organismes communautaires des
banques alimentaires pour distribuer des
tests rapides aux canadiens et aux
canadiennes qui ont recours à leurs
services
je conclurai en vous invitant à
continuer de faire preuve de prudence en
cette période des festivités veuillez
assumez la responsabilité de votre santé
et de celle des autres en suivant les
conseils des responsables de la santé
publique
rx&d est resté prudent faites vous
vacciner si vous n'avez pas encore déjà
fait et si vous y avez droit recevez
votre dose de rappel ces délits l'homme
et on l'a vécu l'an dernier l'effet de
fin d'année sont un moment propice à
transmission du virus ce sont les gestes
que nous prouverons individuellement
dans les prochains jours qui
détermineront notre sort dans les
prochaines semaines et je sais
maintenant la parole à l'ats l'acteur
dame et au dr nuit
bonjour à toutes et à tous pour
l'instant oui en moins d'une semaine
nous avons assisté une accélération
rapide de l'activité épidémique dans
plusieurs régions du canada alors que le
variant delta se propage toujours dans
de nombreuses régions le variant au
micro est de plus en plus responsables
de l'augmentation rapide du nombre de
cas avec plus de 2300 75 microns
confirmés à ce jour ce variant est
maintenant prédominant dans plusieurs
régions au pays
alors que la moyenne nationale était de
plus de 5000 nouveaux cas signalés
quotidiennement à la fin de la semaine
dernière on comptait plus de onze mille
300 nouveaux cas pour la seule journée
d'hier la modélisation montre que d'ici
le 1er janvier nous pourrions avoir une
moyenne que 6e très élevé ce qui est dit
que nous devons agir de toute urgence
pour réduire l'accélération à l'heure
actuelle les tendances des cas de
maladies graves augmentent dans les
provinces les plus touchées ce qui a
commencé à inverser la tendance
nationale au cours de la semaine
dernière en moyenne plus de 1500
personnes à peine de la cobac 19 ont été
traités chaque jour dans nos hôpitaux
dont près de 460 dans des unités de
soins intensifs et 17 décès ont été
signalés chaque jour
bien que les tendances actuelles
puissent être un effet
retardé de l'activité accrue du var un
état au cours des semaines précédentes
l'accélération rapide de l'activité du
variant au micron devraient également
avoir des répercussions sur cette
tendance même si le vernis au micron
s'avère moins graves
nous sommes particulièrement inquiets
des conséquences potentielles d'une
forte et soudaine recrudescence de la
maladie sur le système de soins de santé
c'est pourquoi nous demandons vivement à
tous les caennais de faire ce qu'ils
peuvent pour atténuer ses conséquences
bien que la situation ne soit pas la
même partout ce variant se propage
extrêmement rapidement
et la situation peut très vite devenir
hors de contrôle
n'importe où alors que les autorités de
santé publics surveillent de près
l'évolution de la situation nous pouvons
tous contribuer à réduire nos contacts
le plus possible en termes simples cela
signifie
restreindre la taille des rassemblements
le plus possible par exemple en se
limitant à la famille et aux amis
proches que l'on connaît bien
toutes les personnes admissibles devrait
être entièrement vacciner et obtenir une
dose de rappel dès qu'elles peuvent et
chacun devrait utiliser plusieurs
couches de protection car aucune mesure
n'est parfaite ou applicable à tous en
particulier nous pouvons réduire les
risques d'exposition dus au virus et de
propagation du virus en améliorant et en
maintenant une bonne 26 tentation est
important un match de bonne qualité et
bien ajustés tout en restant flexible
s'il faut changer les projets à la
dernière minute
à l'heure actuelle nous avons toujours
besoin que beaucoup plus de personnes
augmentent leur protection avec les
vaccins contre la coved 19 plus de 7
millions de canadiens admissibles ont
besoin d'une première ou d'une deuxième
dose de leurs primaires et beaucoup
d'autres sont admissibles à une dose de
rappel pour aider à rétablir la
protection qui a pu s'affaiblir depuis
leur deuxième dose les dose de rappel
des vaccins à rnm de phase ii ou de
modern art devrait être administré en
priorité à certains groupes comme les
travers de la santé et les personnes les
plus vulnérables aux maladies graves
causés par la cave es19 notamment les
personnes âgées et les personnes
atteintes d'affections ahoré holloway
donc nous ayons tous à faire face à une
certaine déception est une organisation
de nos projets j'espère que nous sommes
tous d'accord pour dire que nous faisons
tout ce que nous devons faire pour les
bonnes raisons en plus de prendre des
précautions supplémentaires pour
préserver notre santé et celle de nos
proches de nos proches nous adaptons nos
projets afin de protéger notre système
de santé de permettre à chacun de
traverser cette période difficile
beaucoup plus rapidement nous n'avons
déjà mentionné mais je voudrais
remercier tout particulièrement nous
travers la santé de la santé publique
ils ont été là pour nous et on fait de
sacrifices quotidiens que beaucoup
d'entre nous on peine à imaginer
maintenant qu'ils sont confrontés à ceux
qui prêtent à jour la plus grande la
plus soudaine de répercussion un stade
où ils sont sans doute le plus épuisé
doivent savoir que tout le monde
contribue à réduire autant que possible
la menace qui pèse sur nous tous ce ne
sont pas les vacances des fêtes que nous
souhaitions mais cela ne signifie pas
que nous sommes revenus au point de
départ nous disposons d'outils plus
nombreux et plus efficace notamment des
vaccins et des doses de l'appel une
meilleure connaissance de la
transmission et des conseils plus précis
sur les mesures de protection
individuelle ainsi que non plus grand
nombre d'options de dépistage d'une
meilleure fiction clinique de traitement
au cours des prochaines semaines nous
devrons nous appuyer sur ces outils
continuer à travailler ensemble pour
franchir cet obstacle
merci en moins d'une semaine nous avons
assisté à une accélération
de l'activité épidémique donc toujours
régions du canada alors que le baril en
diatta se propage toujours de nombreuses
régions ne verrions au micro et de
prison puisque responsable de
l'augmentation rapide du nombre de cas
avec plus de 2300 64 2 me seront
confirmés à ce jour se verrait en
maîtres dans le prédominant dans
plusieurs régions au pays alors que la
moyenne nationale était de plus en plus
de cinq mille nouveaux cas signalés
quotidiennement à la fin de la semaine
dernière on comptait plus de onze mille
300 nouveaux cas pour la seule journée
d'hier de modélisation montre qu'au
début de janvier nous pourrions avoir un
très grand nombre de cas ce qui souligne
la nécessité d'agir de toute urgence
pour réduire l'accélération à l'heure
actuelle et tendances des cas de
maladies graves augmentent dans les
provinces les plus touchées ce qui a
commencé à inverser la tendance
nationale au cours de la semaine
dernière en moyenne plus de 1500
personnes atteintes de lakovic 19 ont
été traités chaque jour dans nos
hôpitaux dont près de 460 une unité de
soins intensifs et de ces décès ont été
signalés chaque jour bien que les
tendances actuelles puissent être en
effet retardé de l'activité accrue des
variantes diatta au cours des semaines
précédentes l'accélération rapide de
l'activité de dario obertan devrait
également avoir des répercussions de ces
tendances même si le verrions aux
migrants s'avère moins graves nous
sommes particulièrement inquiètes des
conséquences
potentielles d'une forte et soudaine
peut créer des sens de la maladie sur le
système de soins de santé c'est pourquoi
nous demandons vivons à tous les
canadiens de faire ce qu'ils peuvent
pour atténuer ses conséquences bien que
la situation ne soit pas la même partout
ce verrions se propage extrêmement
rapidement et la situation peut très
vite devenir hors de contrôle n'importe
où alors que les autorités de santé
publique serait de près l'évolution de
la situation
nous pouvons tous contribuer à réduire
nos contacts le plus possible en termes
simples cela signifie restreindre la
taille des rassemblements le plus
possible par exemple en se limitant à la
famille et aux amis proches que l'on
connaît bien toutes les personnes
admissibles devrait être entièrement
vague cynique et obtenir un dos de
répéter qu'elles le peuvent et chacun
devrait utiliser que je couche de
protection car aucune mesure n'est
parfaite ou impeccable à tous en
particulier nous pouvons réduire les
risques d'exposition au virus et de
propagation du virus en améliorant et en
maintenant une bonne ventilation et en
portant une marque de bonne qualité et
bien ajustés tout en restant inflexible
il faut changer les projets à la
dernière minute à l'heure actuelle nous
avons toujours besoin de beaucoup plus
de personnes augmente la protection avec
les vaccins contre la copie 19
plus de 7 millions de canadiens
admissibles ont besoin d'une première ou
une deuxième dose de leur série primaire
et beaucoup d'autres sont admissibles à
dos de rappel pour aider à rétablir la
protection qui puisse affaiblir et puis
leur deuxième dose est de ce rappel de
vaccin à à arn messagers de pfizer ou de
moderna devrait être administré en
priorité à certains groupes comme les
travailler à 200 de la santé et aux
personnes les plus vulnérables aux
maladies graves posées par le couvent et
19 notamment les personnes âgées et les
personnes atteintes d'affections à haut
risque
bien que nous ayons tous à faire face à
une certaine déception ayew d'esprit
organisation de nos projets j'espère que
nous sommes tous d'accord pour dire que
nous faisons ce que nous devons faire
les bonnes raisons en plus de prendre
les précautions supplémentaires pour que
j'aie vers notre santé et notre santé et
celle de nos proches nous adaptons nos
projets afin de protéger notre système
de santé est de permettre à chacun de
traverser cette période difficile
beaucoup plus rapidement nous l'avons
déjà mentionné mais je tiens à remercier
tout particulièrement nous travaillera
de la santé et de la santé publique ils
ont été là pour nous et on fait des
sacrifices quotidiens que beaucoup
d'entre nous en peine à la main imaginez
maintenant qu'ils sont confrontés est ce
que pourrait être ce jour la plus grande
et la plus des répercussions à une star
ils sont sans doute plus épuisés et
doivent savoir que tout le monde
contribue à réduire autant que possible
la menace qui pèse sur nous tous
ce n'est pas les vacances est fait et
nous souhaitons mais cela ne signifie
pas que nous sommes revenus au point de
départ nous disposons d'outils plus
nombreux et plus efficace notamment des
vaccins et des douze de rappel une
meilleure connaissance de la
transmission et de concepts plus précis
sur les mesures de protection
individuelle ainsi que deux thèmes plus
grand nombre d'options et dépistage et
d'une mire gestion clinique et des
traitements au cours des prochaines
semaines nous devons nous appuyer sur
six outils et continuer à travailler
ensemble au franchir cet obstacle
merci thank you may watch
tincu ou anne roumanoff
merci nous allons dire passer aux
questions je voulais juste lui rappeler
c'est une question une question de suivi
et le premier ministre peut prendre des
questions pendant 20 minutes et les
autres pourront rester un peu plus
longtemps alizée opérateurs
pourquoi je fais une pile crosstown à me
dreyfus qui partent pour toute question
fait étoiles 1 sur votre appareil
merci de prendre la question monsieur le
premier ministre si vous me permettez
c'est une question un double tranchant
vous savez donner
des nouvelles de personnel en disant que
certains testé positif est-ce que vous
avez près de ce que vous avez passé un
test pcr ou un test rapide et aussi
beaucoup de que deux canadiens ont des
difficultés avec une conversation
difficile avec leur famille et de chez
vous vu que vous avez sans doute aussi
dû changer vos plans pour ce qui est des
fêtes de noël
merci de votre question make love
d'abord nous suivons toutes les
directives de la santé publique à toutes
les étapes aimé et les membres de mon
personnel sont et ce qu'ils sont
maintenant positif suivez aussi
directives comme je le fais et comme
tout le monde le fait moi aussi j'ai eu
j'ai passé des tests les tests sont
négatifs mais je fais très attention
à tout ce que je fais d'ailleurs et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
sommes en virtuel aujourd'hui et
deuxième chose beaucoup de gens ont
découvert ça sans difficulté ressort ne
voulait être dans cette situation
aujourd'hui
on ne s'attendait à passer de belles
fêtes mais maintenant qu'il ya quand
même énormément de gens qui sont
vaccinées au canada on pensait que ça
nous donnerait un peu de répit et qu'on
pourrait se rencontrer avec les familles
célébrer en famille pour célébrer la fin
du coup vu et maintenant nous nous
retrouvons dans cette situation devons
changer nos plans et personne n'avait
envie de se retrouver demain mais mike
vous savez nous savons quoi faire et oui
il ya des conversations difficile de
refuser de voir des amis de bavarder des
grands rassemblements de fêter
simplement avec sa famille proche je
pense que c'est chez nous c'est pareil
que partout donc il ya beaucoup beaucoup
de gens qui doivent avoir des
destructions finalement pour noël
et je pense que
il ya des gens qui seront
malheureusement complètement seul à noël
il y en aura qui auront des difficultés
en termes de santé ou qui auront des
problèmes de santé mentale qui ont
certainement été exacerbée par la
difficulté de ces derniers jours la
plupart d'entre nous nous aurons
peut-être un petit peu moins de
personnes au repas de noël ou aux repas
de fêtes
mais je pense que nous allons survivre
malgré le fait que c'est pas fantastique
mais pensons aux gens qui vont
travailler
dans les hôpitaux d'un les endroits
enfin dans les sections d'urgence et qui
continue à faire absolument tout ce
qu'ils peuvent pour que nous puissions
être en sécurité et pour nous oui ça
sera un petit peu plus difficile mais on
s'adapte en minera justement à quel
point l'hiver sera difficile j'ai une
question de suivi quand vous pensez de
l'expansion à des prestations des choses
ont-elles est vraiment très rapidement
beaucoup plus que pour depuis le début
de la pandémie mais quand on pense à la
première vague
certains
voudraient avait des difficultés à
accéder aux programmes au moment où j'en
avais besoin
mais là tout le monde sait que tout
s'accélère et les prestations n'étaient
pas là mais nous avons pensé à tout cela
nous avons procédé projet de loi comme
ses trois sets 2 et nous savons que
les gens certaines personnes ont eu on a
déjà passé cela la fin de la session
mais on a réussi quand même à faire
voter ses lois donc on va être on a
besoin de faire le règlement mais quand
ça a été créée lorsqu'il ya un
confinement locale nous aurons la panoz
auto development programme donc
toutes les capacités réduites de plus de
50% les personnes sensibles et bien sûr
on aurait beaucoup aimé passer enfin
adopter sa loi beaucoup plus rapidement
mais comme vous savez le parlement à son
propre rythme mais maintenant ces
soutiens sont là donc il s'agit de les
livrer le plus rapidement possible le
canadien qui en ont besoin
merci
la prochaine question nous vient de
battre ou le devoir à vous la parole
bonjour question très simple f que
l'élargissement de l'accès aux ied au
grand prix
s'applique maintenant ou d'entreprises
qui ont été créés durant la part d'élus
bonne question je passais à la parole à
à la vice première ministre
mais c'est le premier ministre la
réponse est non
on utilise la même plateforme les mêmes
règles qu'on a utilisées pour les
subventions salariales et les
subventions pour le loyer
alors ce sont des programmes pour les
entreprises qui étaient là avant le
début de la pandémie les entreprises qui
étaient créées quand personne ne savait
que on aura cette expérience de la lutte
contre une pandémie
merci ensuivie qu'est ce qui est prévu
pour ces personnes à qui on a demandé de
se renouveler et qui ont se sont lancés
en affaires on a parlé plusieurs
personnes le titre semble complètement
démuni de ne pas pouvoir bénéficier des
aides qu'est-ce qui est qu'est ce que
vous leur dites finalement à elles qui
ne sont toujours pas admissibles à ces
nouveaux programmes d aide
ah
je dirais premièrement que comme le
premier ministre a juste expliqué la
chose importante de constater c'est que
le canada est prêt que même en octobre
quand personne ne savait que ceux qui
étaient en micro en mikron on a
savez on a compris que c'était
nécessaire d'avoir une police
d'assurance
on a compris que la lutte contre la
copie n'était pas fini et que ce sera
nécessaire d'avoir les utiles pour
répondre à une manière très vite à une
nouvelle vague de l'aco vide et c'est ce
qu'on a fait commençons en octobre et ce
sont les nouvelles mesures que en a un
en sait aujourd'hui
c'est c'était toujours le cas que oui à
en est là pour les entreprises on est là
pour les gens on est là pour soutenir
l'économie mais on doit avoir une
approche qui a dû l'intégrité on doit
avoir les données avec lesquels on peut
faire une comparaison et nous trouvons
que l' approche la plus juste c'est de
avoir une approche qui a une comparaison
avec les revenus qu'on a maintenant est
celle qu'on a eu des vents le début de
la pandémie
au mr non quoi prochaine question de
mackenzie gré de city vineuse allez-y la
parole est à vous
bonjour monsieur le premier ministre en
ontario et dans d'autres provinces
ya un manque de test les gens font la
file pour tenter d'obtenir un test
rapide
et pour les danses de rappel
c'est une vraie compétition pour pouvoir
en obtenez une en obtenir une
pouvez-vous commenter s'il vous plaît
réponse pour ce qu'il est est rapide
depuis le début des cendres nous avons
envoyé 80 5 millions de tests rapides
aux provinces et territoires au cours de
la dernière année donc ils n'ont pas
tous été utilisés
on va livrer davantage de tests rapides
35 millions de ces tests ce mois ci
il y a des provinces les territoires et
particulièrement la nouvelle écosse qui
fait un excellent boulot
en employant les tests rapides dans les
collectivités dans les entreprises
la preuve vince partagent ces tests avec
les habitants de la nouvelle écosse
ce qui permet une bonne surveillance des
quatre que vides d'autres provinces sont
en train de suivre cet exemple c'est une
bonne chose
comme on l'a promis
le gouvernement
fournit des centaines millions de tests
rapides et mignon tests rapides qui sera
envoyée aux provinces
toutes provinces et aux territoires de
distribuer ces tests rapides aux
habitants pour qu'ils puissent les
utiliser pour ce qui est maintenant des
doses de rappel
lorsqu'on a signé nos accords en matière
de vaccination
on a aussi conclu des ententes
d'achat de doses de vaccin donc des
millions de doses pour 2022 et 2023 et
au delà c'est pour cela que notre
campagne de vaccination va bon train
nous avons assez de dose de rappel au
pays pour tous les gens admissibles à
cette dose de rappel
bien évidemment la distribution peut
parfois poser problème
les provinces sont responsables de la
distribution et nous allons les aider
autant que nous pouvons mais pour ce qui
est du de l'offre
déteste le gouvernement est là
question suivait êtes-vous en isolement
en ce moment
et les gens posent entourage ont-ils été
en contact avec des gens ayant été
déclarés positifs à la cabine réponse
on travaille
à bien comprendre la situation en ce
moment avec les autorités de la santé
publique ottawa à gatineau
à présent on m'a recommandé de
passer un test rapide de faire un test
de dépistage régulièrement jusqu'à
présent j'ai été déclarés négatifs si
jamais je suis déclaré positif je vous
le dirai je vous le promets j'ai aussi
tenté de résumer contact le plus
possible
mais étant donné mes contacts avec le
personnel la santé publique ne me
recommande pas de m'isoler complètement
mais bien entendu je vais continuer à
suivre les directives la santé publique
à la lettre
judy à mme lapointe radio-canada à vous
pendant notre dos
pourquoi ne pas fermer carrément les
frontières étant donné les inquiétudes à
l'heure actuelle que ça demeure une
option est toujours en tête
on est toujours ouvert à n'importe
quelle option qui va garder les
canadiens peu sont situés rites et on a
démontré cela mais la réalité c'est que
au micron est présent au micro et là à
dans nos communautés à travers le pays
acp et de fermer les frontières
maintenant ne serait pas une mesure
efficace comme on a vu pendant 1 les
vagues précédentes
la lise arrivé à la frontière représente
une piscine à partie de la transmission
de covè nous de se concentrer sur
l'interdiction est là et de de
communication ou deux qu'on réponde à la
coved le plus possible pendant le temps
des fêtes dans les communautés c'est
long on veut plus mettre nos ressources
et c'est à ce niveau lors qu'on est en
train de faire tout le travail
nécessaire mais comme j'ai dit on va
suivre la recommandation des sciences de
la santé publique par rapport à ça mais
de fermer les frontières à ce moment ci
ça n'ajouterait pas grand chose pour
beaucoup de perturbations parce qu'il
faut toujours souligné qu' un citoyen
canadien aux résidents permanents en
tout temps revenir au canada on ne peut
pas fermer les frontières aux citoyens
ils ont toujours le droit de venir et la
réalité c'est qu'on est mieux de se
concentrer sur les guitares diction de
communication dans nos communautés mais
je suis content de passer la parole au
ministre la santé pour en dire plus
oui merci monsieur le premier ministre a
choisi beaucoup et je voudrais que au
canada par rapport à tous les pays
comparables dans le nom nous avons
toujours durant la comic 19 et nous
avons encore les mesures frontalières
les plus strictes et les plus efficaces
et ça c'est parce que notre plusieurs
couches de protection là une couche très
importante que j'appelle du lma c'est la
couche de tests avant l'arrivée au pays
qui est une couche uniforme qui
s'applique à tout le monde peu importe
d'où ces gens peuvent venir dès qu'ils
peuvent être une couche additionnel
conomie rapidement place à quelques
semaines qui le paient complète
maintenant qu'il accouche de test à
l'arrivée donc deux couches alors que
dans la plupart des pays du monde ou
encore parfois 0 couche de protection
alors on a fait ça et la deuxième chose
que je joue très rapidement c'est un
appui est ce que monsieur le ministre a
dit c'est que la transmission
communautaire encore plus que pour les
autres warnia la transmission de noter
pour la variole micron c'est la
transcription la plus importante en
raison de la contagiosité de l'infection
caractère très contagieux du nouveau
variant c'est ça qui mène n'y a
présentement c'est les contacts entre
les gens au canada c'est pour ça qu'on
insiste beaucoup sur la réduction des
contacts que les gens doivent faire très
court terme
et pourtant des civils toujours pour m
donc vous avez vu vous mêmes déductions
sur vos plans pour le temps des fêtes un
peu le jour de la marmotte pour que là
on est déjà vaccinées semble plus avoir
de solution miracle
qu'est-ce que vous l'avez dit vous-même
à vos proches qu'est ce que vous diriez
ou jetons canaltech qui sont découragés
face à ce qui nous attend pour les
prochains mois
tu m'as et demi en utah
excusez moi je reprends je comprends à
quel point les gens peuvent être est
épuisée et année par rapport à la coved
19 je comprends n'y a pas personne qui
voulait être dans cette situation aussi
la réalité nos travailleurs de la santé
sont encore plus épuisés sont encore
plus d'années à part la cave et 19e il a
fait ça fait deux ans presque elle qui
travaille extrêmement fort pour me
garder en sécurité et je sais que ça va
être difficile pour bien des familles
comme comme la nôtre de 1,2 rassembler
avec je suis plus proche me c'est ce que
nous devons faire on va voir des moments
au printemps à l'été pour se rassembler
si et seulement si on fait attention
pendant ses temps des fêtes il faut
continuer à faire les bonnes choses de
la bonne façon faut continuer de faire
ce qu'on sait quoi faire on sait comment
le faire de réduire les contacts de
continuer à se faire vacciner d'avoir
les doses de rap est d'assurer la
vaccination nos enfants à porter les
masques et réduire nos contacts c'est
toutes les choses qu'on a su comment
faire et qu'on va pouvoir faire encore
une fois on va passer à travers
l'inclure murge
prochaine question de jordan place
de canard il passe à laisser la parole
est à vous
12h
méfaits premier ministre il y un instant
vous avez dit que nous étions préparés à
l'apparition potentiel de nouveaux
variants cependant malgré les mises en
garde envers un micron
plusieurs régions semblent indiquer une
échec du système et une diminution de la
capacité donc je me demande si vous
croyez que c'est
aux provinces et territoires que revient
la responsabilité et si ce n'est pas le
cas quelle est la responsabilité du
gouvernement fédéral
envers l'échec du système qui semble ne
pas avoir été prêt à pallier un nouveau
variant réponse
nous travaillons d'arrache-pied depuis
deux ans et tentons d'en apprendre le
plus possible sur la coved on se
préparait pour l'arrivée de micro et
lorsqu'il est arrivé nous avons mis en
place des mesures immédiates à la
frontière pour tenter de freiner son
arrivée je crois qu'on a pu gagner un
peu de thym grâce à cette mesure mais
même avant l'apparition de micron au
canada
on a commandé des doses de rappel en
quantité suffisante pour 2022 pour que
chaque canadien admissibles puisse
obtenir cette dose de rappel qui vous
offrira une protection de plus contre le
variant au micro j'encourage les
canadiens à obtenir cette dose de rappel
le plus rapidement possible nous avons
aussi augmenté nos commandes de tests
rapides
à l'automne de 2020
et au cours de la dernière année nous
avons livré près de 100 millions de
tests rapides aux provinces et
territoires on continue d'en commander
encore plus nous en recevrons plus
les questions entourant la distribution
la rapidité d'accès et cetera
sont davantage du ressort des provinces
et territoires
nous sommes toujours là pour les aider
par contre est comme gelée dit la
nouvelle écosse a adopté
l'utilisation des tests rapides très tôt
il était prêt à le faire
et par conséquent ils ont tenu des
résultats positifs ici on va devoir se
serrer les coudes et faire preuve de
prudence les mesures que nous avons mis
en place pour soutenir les entreprises
sont efficaces on a vu qu'il y avait un
besoin pour un programme de soutien 4
confinement locales
et grâce à ces mesures
on a pu aussi ajuster ces mesures pour
élargir les critères d'admissibilité et
ainsi aider
la population contre micron question de
rappel
monsieur le président byden à
communiquer un message à sa population
hier et on sait que lorsque le président
américain dit quelque chose cela résonne
dans les foyers canadiens
hier le président ben ali en a fait des
commentaires sur la période des fêtes
que pensez vous de ce qu'il a dit et
pensez vous que ce qu'il a dit entrera
sans un facteur dans la décision des
canadiens pour les fêtes réponse les
canadiens sont parmi les plus vaccinée
dans le monde les américains
ont plus faibles toute leur population
qui est pleinement vacciner et je crois
que c'est ce à quoi pensez le président
baden lorsqu il vantait les mérites de
la vaccination hier
docteur tom pourra vous en dire plus
mais nous savons que
les gens ayant reçu deux doses de
vaccins peuvent quand même contracté le
variant microns c'est pour cela que
c'est si important d'obtenir une
troisième dose une dose de rappel ce
variant est plus contagieux et se
propage plus rapidement mais la
vaccination
protégera les gens contre d une maladie
grave ou
faire en sorte qu'ils ne se retrouvent
pas aux urgences ou aux soins intensifs
la vaccination est une bonne mesure de
défense contre au micron contre la coved
mais ce n'est pas la seule
mesure de sécurité il faut réduire nos
contacts
pendant cette période des fêtes réduire
la propagation du variant au micro pour
que notre système de santé tiennent le
coup et ne soit pas submergés
si les chiffres explosent ce sera
suffisant pour submerger nos travers de
la santé qui travaillent si fort depuis
deux ans
donc faites vous vacciner
obtenez votre dose de rappel est fait
des choix judicieux
pour cette période des fêtes c'est comme
cela qu'on pourra sortir de cette crise
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on l'a déjà
fait on a réussi à vaincre les vagues
précédentes on sait que les choses
s'améliorent après donc on a simplement
besoin de se serrer les coudes pour les
prochaines semaines l'hiver s'avèrera
peut-être difficile mais on pourra
sortir de cette crise je vais maintenant
donner la parole à la docteure temps
pour qu'elle puisse compléter mes
commentaires en fait c'était une réponse
très complète de la part du premier
ministre selon moi on doit se concentrer
sur la manière façon de gérer cette
variante bal folk swing et nous avons
besoin de réduire les répercussions sur
le système de santé pour éviter
justement des résultats vraiment dur
cette rapide dans cette transmission au
micron va très vite donc on peut pas
détecter tous les cas on peut pas éviter
tous les cas et les chiffres sont
énormes mais
l'important c'est de se concentrer sur
la prévention pour éviter qu'il y ait
plus de répercussions sur le système de
santé
que les travailleurs soient protégés que
la population se protéger sur tout un
peuple est ce un risque
et que disons qu'on fasse les choses
correctement qu'on aille tous
chercher nous rappelle
ce que tout le monde soit en sécurité
c'est vraiment l'objectif principal on
pense que ça peut être fait parce que
tout est là
le point que je voulais
faire c'est pas le nombre de vaccins de
test nous avons des ressources
en
ressources humaines qui ne sont pas
[Musique]
infini donc je pense qu'on peut tous
faire les choses de façon organisée de
la façon ordonnée allait tout est tous
allés chercher nous rappelle
donc on m'a dit que le premier ministre
n'a plus de caisses à plus de temps mais
vrai qu'on a la possibilité lui pose une
dernière question
merci
à les différents projets tva nouvelles à
vous la parole
don de prendre une autre une autre
question je voudrais la demande de
québec pour les forces armées
canadiennes mais cette fois c'est pour
aider à la vaccination
quels types de ressources en eau au sein
des forces qu'elles emploient revêt en
termes de nombre pourrait être déployée
et quand on pourra avoir un espoir un
des membres mais aussi le d'autres
sociétés à la demande on parle aussi de
ressources d'une d'autres organisations
fédérales externe ailleurs dans
l'appareil fédéral
inséré d'aiguillés dans des bois
commercialisés pour la question et c'est
sûr que comme on l'a fait depuis le
début on va être là pour aider les
provinces et territoires qui font face à
des situations difficiles que ce soit
avec la croix rouge que ce soit avec les
forces armées canadiennes on est
justement en train coordonnées le plus
possible pour être là pour aider les
provinces en difficulté la réalité
différemment des vagues précédentes
c'est que au micron est en train de
frapper partout en même temps et on n'a
pas des ressources et finit donc il va
falloir qu'on fasse des choix pour mieux
aider à ce niveau là on est en
conversation avec avec québec éric
d'autres provinces pour vraiment
regarder la de laquelle façon de quelle
façon on peut aider avec le plus
d'impact sachant que nos ressources à
travers le pays sont sont limitées mais
peut-être jean-yves tu es en train de
regarder ça attentivement aussi
tfm alors effectivement la source du
gouvernement canadien sont évidemment l
éviter le gouvernant canadien aussi des
responsabilités envers les communautés
éloignées et certains territoires en
particulier troisièmement les provinces
sont tout comme le disait le premier
ministre dans une situation où il y est
dit dans ces courriers de plus en plus
abordables elles ont toutes évidemment
besoin d'elle et on est ouvert on
pourrait très bien avec elle en août en
compte a crié encore ensemble j'ai parlé
au ministre dubé et hier pour être sûr
de bien comprendre les besoins parce
qu'un quatrième chose effectivement ça
c'est qu'on est en conversation avec
dieu ont bien saisir les besoins
auxquels on pourrait rapidement vous
pouvez rapidement et efficacement à
répondre
donc en collaboration un appui avec lui
merci a suivi la tessiture vous avez une
approximation du nombre qui pourrait
déployer et ou des tableaux casse après
s'être apprécié mais sinon pour mon
suivi les états unis qui ont trouvé
aujourd'hui les traitements tia de haydn
et qui permettrait de réduire les
hospitalisations
le processus est toujours en cours au
canada on a des ententes pour en avoir
jusqu'à 2 millions à ce que c'est
réaliste de penser qu'on pourrait
comme un outil pour des duels de
socialisation sont vraiment au maire de
la guerre sont elles à cause des mesures
qui sont pris dans ce format
j'ai d'avoir un briefing là dessus je
peux vous assurer que santé canada est
en train de travailler extrêmement fort
pour à pour faire l'évaluation
nécessaire pour pouvoir approuver les
choses le plus rapidement possible mais
encore une fois je suis pourtant de
tourner la parole vers le ministre tchao
le ministre la santé
j'ai donc d'une bonne nouvelle est que
santé canada français travaillent
présentement en collaboration avec
d'autres pays qui comme vous dites font
exactement le même travail deuxième
chose c'est qu'on a des contrats
d'approvisionnement solides qui ont des
chiens des signes et quelques semaines
un million de traitements de faveur 500
à 1000 pour meurtre ce sont des
traitements dans faisons le nombre de
gens qui pourraient être profiter de ces
traitements à chaque traitement 6/10
dort ou deux doses par jour durant cinq
jours donc ça va bien à la fois sur le
plan réglementaire et sur le plan de la
réglementation
alapage l'approvisionnement
merci au premier ministre nous allons
rester avec les autres ministres et les
docteurs pendant 20 minutes
supplémentaires merci opérateurs c'est à
vous mais au fil des
génériques en forme de vocation de
mairie comme the globe and mail alessi
d'un après midi
je voudrais revenir sur la question qui
était posée au premier ministre il ya
une message administration américaine
là où ils ont donc un taux de vexations
bien inférieur au nôtre
et il leur a dit profiter des vacances
si vous attaque siné mais on dirait que
on dirait que on doit que vous êtes
presque paniquée en demandant aux gens
de ne pas voir la fin pas de voir leur
famille mais de d'annuler leurs plans je
sais pas comment vous pouvez expliquer
ça aux familles canadiennes
écoutez je vais essayer de vous répondre
est près d'être que
jean-yves va pouvoir élaborer alors
regardez le canada n'est pas les états
unis
mais je crois que nous le savons tous de
façon vraiment profonde
et nos pays ont pris des approches très
différentes dans cette lutte contre la
copie
et je sais que c'est très dur pour tout
le monde au canada en ce moment mais je
crois qu'on devrait peut-être se
rassurer
et prendre confiance du fait que lorsque
nous comparons la façon dont le canada
s'est battu contre ce que vides
et la façon dont d'autres pays
semblables aux nôtres ont géré cette
lutte contre la corrida et bien on peut
se dire que le canada s'est très bien
débrouillé on a le taux le de tous les
mois un des taux de décès les moins
importants dans le g7 et c'est vraiment
important parce que nous avons été
capables de nous soutenir les uns des
autres on a été en mesure de
l'économiser beaucoup de pain de sauver
des vies en fait et
ce que je voudrais être sûr que je
voudrais insister c'est la notion que le
gouvernement fédéral
et je dirais même aussi les
gouvernements provinciaux et
territoriaux
c'est que nous avons nous le sortent
nous ne voulons pas envoyer un conseil
de panique ou un conseil de désespoir au
contraire bien au contraire nous pensons
que les canadiens devraient
avoir l'espoir parce que nous sommes
prêts en tant que pays
nous avons les mesures économiques
économique en place et en fait on ya
pensé même avant déjà en octobre nous
avons mis en place
des lois avec une certaine flexibilité
qui nous permet de réagir très
rapidement à ce genre de situation et
nous avons commandé des rappels de tests
rapides et de médicaments justement pour
le l'éventualité de cette situation et
nous avons aussi mis l'argent pour payer
pour tout cela
et comme jean-yves
l'a souligné en tant que pays on s'est
bien débrouillé non seulement pour
acheter les vaccins mais pour vacciner
tout le monde fin ou presque et comme
vous verrez dans l'expérience de
beaucoup de nombreux pays ce n'est pas
si facile à faire et je crois que en
tant que canadiens on devrait être
rassurée parce que on a une était
capable nationalement de gérer la cabine
on a eu une résilience nationale on a
les outils à la fois économique et
d'hygiène et de santé et
du fait que le gouvernement fédéral et
les gouvernements provinciaux et
territoriaux travaille bien ensemble de
la même chose pour les ministères de
l'assemblée ministre de la santé
je dirais que le message en faible que
nous aimerions transmettre canadien
c'est que oui c'est vrai c'est dur et ça
arrive au mauvais moment quand tout le
monde est fatigué et on était vraiment
prêt à se relaxer et être en famille
mais malgré tout nous avons fait du bon
travail en tant que pays et on est un
pays qui fait très attention et qui
je pense que nous devons tous faire très
attention
mais moi j'ai confiance que nous ferons
ai-je eu confiance en notre résilience
et je suis sûr que nous allons vaincre
est là que vide et c'est le message
peut-être du gouvernement du canada à
tous les niveaux des
deux dirigeants canadiens ou pas aux
gens parce que moi c'est exactement ce
que je vois les gens autour de moi les
canadiens sont responsables son fond les
choses de façon intelligente ils pensent
de façon urgente leur propre santé la
santé dans leur communauté
awake régler
très rapidement oui on a été on a bien
réussi
bien sûr on n'est pas parfait mais c'est
évident que si on se compare à d'autres
pays on a vraiment réussi beaucoup de
de cela on a quand même été en mesure de
protéger la sécurité la santé des
canadiens et comme vous dites beaucoup
moins de canalisations sont décédés que
dans d'autres pays aux etats unis le
taux de décès et trois fois d'un taux
canadien alors ça veut dire que si on
avait eu le même taux de décès que celui
des états unis on aurait eu soixante
mille personnes
de plus ce curé qui seraient mortes au
canada de la copine
merci je voudrais faire une question de
suivi il me semble que le message des
états unis
et contrairement au prince c'est de ne
pas paniquer et de
profiter de leurs vacances mais le
message du canada est différente c'est
comme eux essayent d'éviter le
confinement mais nous on se prépare au
confinement se prépare à des
restrictions
et
si je comprends bien
comme le gouvernement voire
ans on voit des tests aux provinces
pourquoi le gouvernement fédéral n'en
voit pas directement des tests aux
canadiens par l'intermédiaire de la
croix rouge
eh bien oui car
je vais c'est de répondre à votre
question
encore une fois je vais dire par répéter
le canada n'est pas les états unis je
pense que les canadiens sur le savent
bien
en fait nous sommes tout à fait
conscients des choix de notre pays est
fier du choix de notre pays nous faisons
beaucoup nous avons beaucoup de nos
choix sont différents de ceux des états
unis sur beaucoup de sujets et je
voudrais souvenez vous utilisez le terme
panique mais je voudrais vraiment dire
que ce n'est pas du tout l'attitude de
notre gouvernement dans toutes les
conversations qu'on a eues avec les
provinces et territoires les
municipalités
ce n'est pas du tout l'attitude
non plus
mais
par contre nous sommes nous prenons une
approche
prudente
nous faisons attention nous nous
concentrons sur le fait que nous voulons
suivre les différents signes nous
voulons sauver des vies
et du point de vue économique et
financier puisque je suis ministre des
finances nous avons compris depuis le
début de la pandémie que la politique
économique forte avec une politique de
santé forte c'est une bonne chose et
nous continuons cette approche
on comprend et on respecte les champs de
compétence des provinces et territoires
c'est à eux de prendre des décisions de
santé publique
surtout au niveau local
au gouvernement fédéral on sait que
c'est très difficile de prendre ces
décisions on sait que c'est difficile
pour les provinces et territoires et les
municipalités de choisir de restreindre
ce que peuvent faire les entreprises et
les personnes et mesures de soutien
annoncées aujourd'hui sont là pour aider
[Musique]
les autorités de santé publique au
niveau municipal et provincial à prendre
les bonnes décisions pour garantir la
sécurité des canadiens
jeu
hier d'avoir
que nous ayons adopter les mesures
législatives pour pouvoir offrir ce
soutien je suis
nous avons alloué des fonds
dans la mise à jour économique d'automne
pour
financer donc ces mesures d' aide on
croit en la résilience et on va
continuer à aider les canadiens comme on
le fait depuis le début non
bon alors pour ceux et celles qui
viennent de se joindre à nous sachez
qu'au cours de la dernière heure on a
entendu les autorités fédérales avec en
tête le premier ministre justin trudeau
également les autorités de santé
publique fédérale faire le point sur
l'état de lakovic 19 à travers le pays
et
[Musique]